numerous times police officers have told
me that they got more important cases to
deal with when Marlon first contacted us
a year ago he was in despair his teenage
daughter was receiving threats
a message with this video Read you're
ignoring me I'm coming to shoot your dad
a balaclava man had delivered a menacing
letter to the house
and she was repeatedly going missing at
this stage Marlon didn't want to be
identified but was convinced his
daughter was being sexually exploited
and says greater Manchester police
wouldn't listen
so I've been shouted out animated by an
officer from the missing persons team at
GMP
um telling me to stop reporting my
daughter missing a time when that
happened she was 14 years old
so what was really happening here in
Hyde in Greater Manchester Marlon's
daughter Scarlett now 18 has waived her
anonymity to talk about it her father
was right she was being sexually
exploited by older men
the next morning with our Breeze is up
my legs but won't know where they'd come
from but there'd be big breezes you know
so it's not like I banged into something
like see things in the morning like
condoms on the side or like sex ties are
just drinks big bottles of vodka like
you know cocaine packets are just it's
the next one and I'd kind of just wake
up and see the room what mess it was in
Scarlett has also shared this video she
says was filmed by her abusers while she
slept
and this of injuries to her face she
says once they made her eat cigarette
butts and sometimes she was picked up by
the police with the men with older men
the police won't even arrest him it'd
just be like because we'd be on a car
park at three in the morning it'd just
be like one of them things like what
you're doing here and they didn't
interview you say what are you doing
with a grown man who's not a relative at
3am in the morning they just took me
home and said to my dad she's been found
in a car in Mosley on a car park
with older guys what do you think they
should have been doing she's like asking
me what was actually going on
she says it all began when she reported
being physically and sexually assaulted
by gang aged 14. she felt police didn't
investigate properly and her own
behavior became more unstable she was
groomed by a woman she trusted into
sexual exploitation
and my dad would know where I am you'd
know like well not all the times but you
know I'd be with this one person yeah
and it'd be like reporting me missing
and then
I have the police not coming and I've
made my own way home or the police come
in take me back and saying to me give it
five minutes till we've left for you to
go again yeah like the police had say
that to me they'd say good give it five
minutes till we've left because we know
you're gonna go again so just wait till
we've gone
once after her father reported her
missing officers finally arrived at his
home in the dead of night
just a little tap one appears to say
Marlon thinks because they didn't want
to get involved
[Applause]
you've been driving around
most nights until three four o'clock in
the morning trying to find her and at
one point I did find her out of property
a scene ago at the property
I contacted contacted the place that
told me there was someone over there in
10 minutes and this was about midnight
in the middle of the winter
and I was still there at 4am wave the
police
as a senior health worker who understood
child safeguarding Marlon knew the
protocols to rescue his daughter from
her groomer but in a text exchange
Social Services said they cannot apply
for a recovery order as the child has to
be on a care order and we can't apply
for a child abduction warning notice the
police have to but the police texted in
order to do this we would need Social
Services to apply for a recovery order
so everyone washing their hands yeah
whilst my daughter
was missing for home for two weeks and
being more traumatized from from the
experience that we've been growing being
sexually exploited yes
only three years later did police impose
a child abduction warning notice on the
person who was allegedly grooming
Scarlet
it's very rare for recent victims of
this kind of abuse to tell their story
and while greater Manchester police has
apologized for failing historical
victims in the Rochdale grooming case
here we are again with what seems like a
repeat of the same blind spot to obvious
signs of child exploitation even when a
distraught father is doing everything he
can to draw it to their attention
in response gmp's Chief superintendent
Michaela Kerr said in recent years and
in recognition of previous failures the
force has worked hard to ensure the
consistent delivery of outstanding
service which fights crime keeps people
safe and cares for victims she said in
this case complaints have been resolved
directly with the complainant and none
of the outcomes have so far been
appealed key to par police continue to
work on the case and say safeguarding
and vulnerable people is a priority
thameside Council said they were legally
unable to comment but they work closely
with families to provide support
what would you say to your younger self
but everything my dad did for me was to
like keep me safe and I did not see that
at the time do you know for years when I
say this didn't bother me I didn't think
I just didn't think it was anything
special to even talk about that I didn't
think anyone would be interested in
what's happened to me and
I kept it in for so many years and it's
like me coming out speaking about this
someone might say oh do you know what
I'm I've been in the same situation as
Urban it's like there's things you can
do do you know what I mean not just to
stay silent and suffer
Scarlett lost her childhood and her
education she went into the care system
several times where she also went
missing
so the phone calls were being monitored
while Marlon amassed files of
Correspondence and complaints and paid
for therapy
four years on from when it began they
now have each other but little faith in
anyone else
Jason Farrell Sky News